CNN has obtained the audio of Donald
Trump in 2021 talking about classified
documents that he has this audio which I
am going to play for you
contradicts many of Donald Trump's
recent claims during interviews about
classified documents it also contradicts
Trump's claims that he Declassified
everything while President remember this
is one of the arguments well I can't
possibly get in trouble for what I did
with classified documents after leaving
office because I Declassified all of it
if that were the case we wouldn't have
Trump on an audio recording saying these
are classified because he would have
Declassified them CNN exclusive CNN
obtains the tape of Trump's 2021
conversation about classified documents
let's just play it this first aired last
night on Anderson Cooper's program it is
extraordinary and at the top level it is
notable for two reasons number one it
exposes Trump's crimes number two it
exposes Trump's lies and of course they
are in many cases interwoven sick
people that was your cue you know
against you well it started right when
Millie's talking about oh you were going
to try to do a kick no they were trying
to do that before you even were sworn in
that's right trying to overthrow your
life well with Millie uh let me see that
I'll show you an example he said that I
wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him they presented me this is
off the Record but okay so Trump first
says this is off the Record that's not
indicative of anything related to the
classification status of the document so
far no issue let's continue
they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
somehow there's a secret information
look at this you attack and Hillary
would print that out all the time
I should send it to Anthony Weiner
by the way is that incredible yeah I was
just saying because we were talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
Trump said as president I could have
Declassified it and a staffer says yeah
and laughs and then Trump says now I
can't you know but this is still a
secret why would you say you could have
Declassified something if you did
declassify all the documents there
whether Trump is now claiming he
telepathically Declassified whether
Trump is claiming that there was any
default declassification that happens
when he takes something it doesn't
matter what mechanism he cites for
declassification as bogus as those
methods may be he says right here this
is still Secret
I could have Declassified it but now I
can't let's listen to the last few
seconds
isn't that interesting yeah it's so cool
I mean it's so I'm look we here and I
have a
and you probably almost didn't believe
me but now you believe me no I believe
it's incredible right no they bring some
bring some Cokes in please so there
Trump calls for sodas uh calls for Cokes
to be brought in to sort of celebrate
the disclosure of classified documents
to people who are not clear to do that
so this is extraordinarily damning this
is going to be uh an exhibit for sure in
the forthcoming either criminal trial of
trump or something that will be
presented by prosecutors at possible
plea negotiations to say look at what we
have we've got you you might be better
off taking a plea now not only is it
abundantly clear that this is part of
the criminality it's also important to
understand that Trump with absolutely no
hesitation whatsoever no qualms No No
Reservations at all regularly lies about
this stuff here is Donald Trump in that
whacked out interview last week on Fox
news with Brett Baier
um which was covered while I was away
saying there was nothing to declassify
because these were newspaper stories and
and articles uh that he had and was
showing people but of course we know
that that is a lie here is Trump with a
totally straight face as straight as
Trump's face can be uh lying to Brett
Baier
there was no document that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things and
it may have been held up or may not but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se there was nothing to
declass with these were newspaper
stories magazine stories okay it is
abundantly clear folks I mean I I know
that we on the left have a problem and
the problem is when we see something
like this we say this is it folks we've
there is nothing that these people can
come up with now to explain this away
and then they come up with something
they go no Trump misspoke here or he
misspoke their Trump thought the
document was classified but it really
wasn't it was just Trump's mistake
they will always have some way to try to
weasel out of it but we don't care about
that what we care about is what is going
to happen in a court of law because
these are now legal proceedings these
are legal proceedings Trump says to
Brett Bayer I these weren't classified
documents in that conversation remember
that interview was before the audio
leaked the interview was pre-audio leak
Trump says I was showing people
newspaper articles in the audio
recording released by CNN Trump is
clearly referring to documents from the
Department of Defense he's not saying
look at what they wrote In The New York
Times or whatever he's clearly referring
to government documents and he knows
that they are classified
that he didn't declassify them as
president that he can no longer
declassify them as an ex-president and
that it is not something that he should
be showing people this is evidence of
exactly the criminality
with which Donald Trump has been charged
make sure you subscribe to the YouTube
channel my friends in may we had more
than 3 million people watch our clips
but not subscribe if just 10 of that 3
million subscribes right now we will get
to the two million dollar assuming 2
million subscriber uh line on YouTube
very very strongly and quickly uh we'll
take a quick break and be right back
whether you're a carpenter painter or
just want to be prepared for emergencies
if you need a gas mask or respirator go
to our sponsor parcel safety as many of
you know I'm into emergency preparedness
not crazy prepping but I want to have
some food stored some supplies I've
talked about water and multiple
respirators are part of that because
it's just a staple of being prepared
respirator sales have been way up in
recent years natural disasters wildfires
polluted air chemical plant accidents on
rest of different kinds militarized
police all sorts of different reasons
you never know when a respirator or a
gas mask from parcel safety might come
in handy and it could be when you least
expect it parcel safety respirators are
also perfect for professionals
contractors painters people doing DIY
projects at home all of parcel safety's
respirators come with a one-year
manufacturer's warranty every respirator
or gas mask comes with a filter
competitive prices large discounts for
organizations and outstanding customer
service to be totally honest I've said
before I'm using these for changing baby
diapers it's people think I'm kidding
and then they come visit me and I really
am not it it actually is very useful to
other parents out there I do recommend
it go to davidpackman.com safety use the
code Pacman for 25 off your first order
the link is down below